alou maison pardon je vous appelle
depuis un téléphone portable j'ai trouvé
chaque année dans les contacts y en
avait un qui s'appelait maison alors
voilà je peux connaître votre prénom
vous continuez à vous appeler maison
qu'est ce que vous faites au juste
d'ailleurs je pars avec vous c'est
plutôt agréable
une opportunité mais de quoi elle s'est
emportée pour qui exactement pour moi je
vous d'accord et qu'est ce que j'ai
gagné phone un téléphone mais c'est mon
téléphone
oui mais c'est moi qui l'ait déjà riche
fait glace crème et des lave ou demain
14 heures ça vous va et il commença pour
se reconnaître
vous verrez pourrais pas me rater maison
ça va oui très bien oui à au pointage